hello everyone and welcome to another
really exciting game from the world
rapids championship that uh ended uh uh
a little while ago it's a game between
timor garev and fabiana caruana i knew i
was going to cover this game i just
didn't know when exactly but a lot of
you have requested it so here it is it's
completely out of this world uh you guys
will enjoy it so yeah let's dive
straight into it so we're gonna have
with the white pieces uh opens with d4
we have knight to f6 by fabi uh c for e6
knight to c3 and the bishop to b4 the
nimzo indian defense is on the board
which usually means that it's going to
be a a very very enjoyable game so here
we have queen to c2 going for the
classical variation castles by black and
now a3 the standard idea we want to
challenge black's bishop and ask black
what do you want to do do you want to go
back but always black captures here so
we have bishop captures and now we don't
want to ruin our pawn structure so we're
going to capture with the queen kind of
why we played queen to c2 so here queen
captures on c3
we have d6 and now knight to f3 so this
is all very standard stuff nothing new
here we have rook to e8 preparing e5 and
bishop to g5 developing and pinning the
knight on f6 with h6 and now bishop to
h4
and there is a game in the database
where queen to e7 was played but here we
have g5 by caruana and it is now as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how gareth deals
with this g5 push we have bishop to g3
anything else is pretty much pointless
and now e5 striking in the center uh
graves king still occupies d1 square so
we want to open up the center and attack
the white king and the the idea is of
course uh
you can't just uh for example capture an
e5 i mean you could but then knight e4
uh can be somewhat pleasant now what do
you do with the queen for example if
queen e3 attacking the knight bishop f5
and black is getting a lot of
development in for that one pawn and
well the white king is still on e1 so
it's a it's a very
well it's it's a crazy position so
instead after e5 uh grave just castles
queen side which is uh well very
interesting uh and now comes knight to
e4 attacking the queen and the bishop
like in the previous line but now queen
to e1 and now f5 now fabi's threatening
f4 to trap the bishop on g3 and here
comes d captures on e5 and i believe
agarev had everything prepared
up to this point and maybe a few moves
further because it all uh makes sense
and it all
is the strongest reply by the engine so
here he's offering the g3 bishop but
you'll see it's not uh you know it's not
all that black and white so here f4
trapping the bishop and now e3 uh
another very very good move preparing
bishop to d3 to attack the knight but
also we're just threatening to free our
bishop with e captures on f4 so fabi has
to capture on g3 otherwise what is he
really doing we have h captures and g3
now you also have to worry about the h6
pawn and queen to e7 now uh developing
the queen you couldn't capture here with
the pawn or the rook or the rook uh
because the the knight guards the pawn
and the the rook pins the pawn so uh you
have to move the queen first now comes
bishop to d3 attacking the knight and
the bishop to f5 now and it's uh uh like
i said this is a crazy game and there
are a lot of good potential positive
video moments but this is the one i
really enjoy because it's so early on in
the game so feel free to pause the video
here and win the game for gareth while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it uh congratulations on spotting the
move gareth played uh rook captures an
h6 uh or knight to d4 also a fine idea
going after the the bishop but there is
one move that is even more precise than
these two and that is g4 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this and i know a lot of you guys were
thinking about b4 but no this is one
rare occasion where b4 does not win the
game uh it's actually g4 the the idea is
that if the bishop moves from this
diagonal we simply pick up the knight on
e4 and it doesn't matter if the bishop
goes back to g6 or h7 the are pretty
much all the moves are the same for
example bishop h7 we capture on h6 and
now whatever black plays we don't really
care we just capture the bishop here and
after queen captures now there's knight
captures on g5 attacking the queen we're
gonna win the knight here after the
queen moves knight captures on e4 and
okay let's say rook captures on e5 we're
gonna play f4 and the black king is
completely wide open here yes black is
up the exchange but look at those pawns
coming after the the black king and well
it's just impossible to defend this with
black so this was one way to do it
however in the game rook captures on h6
was played so i believe this was already
out of preparation
and now queen to g7 attacking the rook
here and now knight to d4 offering the
rook for knight captures on f5
but here comes the bishop to g4 now
fabi's attacking the rook on d1 and also
the rook on h6
so here rook back to h2 uh we want to
save this rook and now not captures a
bishop captures on d1 because if you go
for this then we play bishop captures on
e4 and the white is just winning your
bishop is hanging here and once you move
the bishop the queen to h1 now
rook can come to h7 b7 bone is saying
you're going to lose the rook there's
too many threats to defend all of them
so instead after rook h2 we have d
captures on e5 now attacking the knight
but now b
bishop captures an e4
we have e captures on d4 and now another
beautiful moment where
white is completely winning but you have
to play it precisely
and you have to play bishop to d5 with
check this is a rapid game so of course
players don't have all that much time to
spot the moves but i will show it as
it's very interesting so here you have
to play bishop to d5 check the rook
controls the h file so the king can't
really move to the h file you have to
play king f8 now there's queen b for
check and now after you block with queen
e7 rook to h8 to check once the king
moves we're going to play queen captures
on e7 rook captures on e7 and now rook d
h1 and there is not all that much black
can do here his position is uh is is
extremely bad even though uh for the
moment he he does have two two pieces
for the for the rook but uh it's not
gonna be
um
uh it's not gonna be uh easy to or or
rather he's up a piece but uh he will
not be able to
uh defend this position for example d
captures an e3 we're going to play rook
1 to h7 check and after the king moves
we're going to play rook to f8 to check
and now the rook falls and we are of
course winning king e5 rook captures and
e7 with the check now we are up the
exchange and of course it's a completely
winning position for white however here
rook captures and d4 was played thinking
okay it's all the same uh but now at
least i control this square i can get
the rook into the game more easily i'm
still attacking b7 if i ever want to
capture this but now fabi brings another
defender into the game and this is the
the last moment where uh white can seize
advantage with bishop at the h7 check uh
point is that
the queen has to capture the bishop if
you play king f7 then we capture on g4
and then well it's just
again completely winning for white uh
it's a com it's a really crazy position
so in
with the time on the clock being low
it's not easy to go for this but this
was the way to go uh in the game bishop
captures and c6 was played but now uh he
missed one uh reply that fabi can make
and this is just a complete game changer
so feel free to pause the video once
again and now if i try to find a way out
the only way out for fabi uh from this
position while i give you a couple of
more
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on realizing
the queen on e1 is undefended and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show of course queen captures on d4 we
can even do a slow motion capture here
nicely like this queen captures on d4
and now what do you do if you capture
you lose the queen with check so what
are your options here now you could
capture the uh the rook here but then
comes queen captures on c4 and this is
just terrible king to b1 we're gonna
capture on e8 and now black is up a
bishop of course completely winning uh
so you don't want to do that so here
bishop back to d5 check was played you
don't want your bishop here on c6
waiting to be captured king to f8 and
now rook to h7 so it seems like gareth
still has a couple of tricks up his
sleeve
but now queen to f6 the only way to
defend this position because you have to
be ready for rook f7 and here giving up
the
queen would be
very much in favor for for black for
example captures captures and captures
you have two rooks and a bishop you
would be okay here uh so instead we have
queen to b4 with check rook to e7
blocking and only now rook to f7 check
as there simply isn't anything better
queen captures we have bishop characters
king captures the rook is pinned and now
f3 so now it's uh at uh gareth's queen
against two rooks and the bishop but the
king is wide open uh so it's very
unlikely that you will be able to push
for something here if you had a pawn or
two to defend your king then black would
be you know i don't want to favor here
so bishop back to e6 we have queen
captures on b7 now comes rook to d8 we
have queen captures an a7 and now bishop
captures in c4 and even though this
might be an equalish position this is a
rapid chess and of course
many things can go wrong so queen c5
attacking the bishop bishop back to a6
now comes queen captures on g5 we have
rook to d5 and now queen to f4 would
check now uh fabi can block or hide with
the king um
uh he decides to block with rook to f5
we have queen to b4 and now rook to d7
we have e4 now not allowing any rook to
e4 ideas to go for rook d1 so rook the
h5 trying to attack the white king from
behind and now queen to c3
we have rook to h2 going after the g2
pawn now comes queen to e3 and now rook
captures on g2 we have a4 uh gareth
starts pushing his pass pawn now rook d6
maybe we can create some sort of a
blockade here as we do not want to
despawn crossing the a6 square so queen
c5 first going after the pawn and now
bishop to d7 attacking the pawn but it
doesn't matter uh of course we don't
capture on c7 if any of you guys were
thinking about this shame on you rook to
c6
would um
lose you the queen so after bishop to d7
queen to h5 check we have king to f8 now
comes queen to h8 to check king e7 uh
queen to h4 check and now came to f7 and
it seems that black king will not be
able to find any sort of safe haven so
queen h7 check king to f6 we have queen
to hit check king of seven queen to h7
czech uh king the e8 queen the h8 check
king the e7 uh queen the h4 wit check
king the e8 and it was in this position
that uh gareth and karana agreed to a
draw as there is nothing more to be done
here it would be too dangerous to to try
something for example if you try let's
say queen h8 check now you want to get
your king deeper into the position let's
take king e6 after f4 look at these
pawns it's already
could be very uncomfortable for for the
black king it's still a draw but uh with
little time on the clock you don't want
to allow such things so after king 38
they agreed to a draw
and uh what a miraculous escape by fabi
and what a brilliant attacking game by
gare that uh peace sacrifice uh you know
in the beginning was just uh incredible
uh and you know just allowing this
bishop to be trapped like this after
this f4 f4 move is uh uh completely uh
insane and you know it it just shows you
what uh what what a creative player gary
is and what uh
uh incredible positions can arise from
the nimzo indian defense uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and i actually have uh two photos for
you uh to enjoy after the game uh so
here is one photo this is uh
and jobawa here uh you can see they are
both very aggressive and very uh you
know imaginative players and you can see
they are always having a good time and
that's the way you wanna
be playing chess so i'm very happy that
um
they have such a nice photo taken uh by
david lada uh and also here is a nice
one by leonard otis uh this is also
gareth here you can see that he's
wearing a full chest wardrobe uh and
beneath that there is a dragon ball
t-shirt so uh i like it all uh i just
thought i thought maybe some of you guys
would enjoy this as well you know a
little bit of uh positive energy in your
life uh as
uh gareth seems to be bursting with that
uh so yeah
that's the game and some nice photos
hope you guys enjoyed that uh i would
like to thank uh dylan holloway pat
kopinger mother imam global tennis
network and duress press for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh the
uh well uh to check up on everything
that's happening in the chess world and
of course on your wonderful suggestions
and well pretty much everything else
that we do here uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and uh i am preparing a
chess quiz uh so you know be ready for
that as well uh see you soon